CNN is holding a town hall event tonight
for Donald Trump in Saint Anselm at St
Anselm College in New Hampshire this was
already a very high stakes media event
in the sense that this is not a normal
person this is not I don't know you know
uh sununu's running and we're going to
do a town hall or whatever the case may
be Mitt Romney you know this is uh one
of the most destructive forces to ever
hold the White House who was impeached
twice has been arrested and charged was
just found liable of sexual assault and
defamation and owes e Gene Carroll five
million dollars incited an Insurrection
to try to remain in the White House
despite having lost an election which to
this day he claims he actually won
this is not a normal person and so from
a media ratings and profit perspective I
understand why CNN is giving Trump a
town hall I get it I don't yet want to
pass judgment as to whether it will be a
responsible or irresponsible thing to do
because I want to see how CNN handles it
at this point in time
how do you not bring up
the sexual assault decision from that
jury how do you not bring up January 6th
how do you not bring up the arrest and
the likely additional forthcoming arrest
in Georgia that we expect to happen
sometime between July and August
are they going to handle this
responsibly or is it going to be Mr
Trump what will you do to stop Biden
Marxism if you were to get another term
in office right if it's that okay if
it's if that's the type of thing we're
going to see this may be one of the most
irresponsible media events that we ever
uh witnessed now which of the two is it
going to be I don't know the Associated
Press CNN's town hall with Trump takes
on higher Stakes after sexual abuse
verdict Trump will return to CNN's
Airwaves Wednesday joining the network
for a two-hour Town Hall event in early
voting New Hampshire a day after a civil
jury found him liable for sexually
assaulting an advice columnist nearly
three decades ago
The Forum which was announced last week
was expected to be notable because it
would be bringing together a network and
a candidate who have sparred with each
other but the stakes raised considerably
Tuesday after jurors in New York found
Trump sexually abused and defamed Gene
Carroll though it rejected her claim
that he raped her the jury awarded her
five million dollars in charges it also
returns Focus to questions over Trump's
treatment of women over the years yeah
raising the stakes for an event at which
he will be forced to respond to tough
questioning from host Caitlin Collins in
the audience well we don't know that
will it be tough questioning I don't
know
Carol is more than one more than a dozen
women one of more than a dozen women who
accuse Trump of sexual assault or
harassment I think the number is
actually closer to 50.
Trump has historically not reacted well
when pressed on stage about his behavior
toward women most notably during the
first debate in 2015 when he sparred
with Fox host Megan Kelly he later said
she had blood coming out of her whatever
when she was questioning him that was an
insane moment so uh I I am
um sort of maintaining an open mind or
whatever you would say and many of you
have written to me and said David you
don't need to keep an open mind what
what CNN is going to do is completely
irresponsible it's going to be nuts now
let's address a little bit about my
plans for coverage of this event my plan
was to stream the town hall live and
then to do a sort of retrospective on it
on tomorrow's show
let's deal with two parts of that am I
going to do that and then morally what
do I think about the whole thing let's
actually start with the morally first
I believe that what CNN is going to do
tonight may be completely completely
immoral journalistically but it may not
I want to wait and see how it goes I
want to see how Caitlin Collins handles
it I want to see what sort of questions
are selected the entire thing
um
my plan to cover it live tonight and to
discuss it tomorrow you know a few
people wrote to me and said David you're
doing something just as bad as CNN no I
with peace and love I completely reject
that notion we do a program that is
heavily centered around media analysis
and media criticism whether I talk about
the fact that this event took place or
not it's taking place I have nothing to
do with the fact that it's taking place
and I want to cover it in order to
analyze how CNN handles the event okay
so I don't have you know the idea that
I'm doing the same thing CNN is doing by
talking about or covering the event I
reject it completely we do media
analysis we do media criticism here now
that being said am I actually going to
cover the event live tonight no and the
reason why is CNN our YouTube rep and
our twitch contact both and we have
nobody at Facebook but I'm gonna assume
it's the same thing
twitch and YouTube have told me CNN
plans to go really hard against anyone
who broadcasts that event live tonight
um they will shut you down they will
shut you down on YouTube they will shut
you down on Twitch and you know what I
believe it because CNN has done it
before so the plan for tonight is I'm
going to stream a pre-show we are going
to have
Clips interviews with people on the
ground there at Saint Anselm in New
Hampshire we're going to discuss the
context surrounding this event going
live at 7 30 PM Eastern the event starts
at 9 00 PM I believe let me just verify
that Trump Town Hall New Hampshire May
10 start time it was scheduled for nine
I want to make sure that's the case CNN
says how to watch
um
oh it's 8 P.M okay so let's actually do
it differently it starts at 8pm I will
go live at 7 pm Eastern we'll do an hour
pre-show and then we'll end the stream
and if you want to watch the event you
can go and watch it from 8 to 10 on an
official platform CNN online or whatever
and if you don't want to watch it then I
will do a retrospective of it tomorrow
so that's our plan I will be watching
for do they actually bring quote tough
questions to Trump is Trump held
accountable is Trump treated as the
abnormal president that he was and and
the abnormal candidate that he that he
is or does CNN normalize him all
questions which we will find out answers
to tonight join me at 7 pm Eastern I
will see you then